how's it going oh that's not I didn't
okay well let me put a timer on so I
don't go over time did you guys enjoy
the keynote I did not go I'm feel kind
of bad but I feel like whenever you
speak at a conference you're kind of
like what can I actually go see whenever
I do singletrack conferences so I can
actually see my friends and you can
actually pay attention a little bit more
but it's so easy to get distracted with
a hallway track these days so how many
of you all are angular developers how
many of you are react developers so how
many of you guys use angular material
she okay maybe okay okay okay
well angular definitely made a lot of
really cool releases recently which I'm
excited about so if your company is not
excited about the material design
aspects of it there's some new releases
that I'll talk about later in this talk
so my name is Tracy you can follow me on
twitter at lady leet I am a speaker at
Google developer expert as well for
angular and other web technologies
I love JavaScript so anything angular
ember react rxjs react native native
script basically anything javascript you
can probably find me poking around with
not view yet how many of you guys used
to view
none wow it's amazing I guess we're not
in China or India or anything like that
a lot of my friends these days they're
like large companies in the US are
starting to move to view which is
interesting so we'll see how that goes
um I do want to try it though so I'm
also a co-founder of a company called
this dot on the media side we have this
amazing quarterly event called this
JavaScript where we bring together the
core contributors of the different
frameworks and libraries like angular
ember react view rxjs polymer etc so you
can find that live broadcasted every
quarter or you can just pick it up
online as well
we also do one with browser vendors so
there's a lot of really cool things
happening with edge and
Chrome obviously but I mean even more
excitingly I feel like people ignore
edge a lot and if you heard this state
of edge that Nolan Lawson gave recently
you guys would be like oh my gosh this
is so cool so anyways on the lab side we
do more of a consulting type approach
but one thing I'm really excited about
is this diversity program that we're
just launching so if you care about
hiring women in tech and care about that
initiative what we do is we mentor up
junior developers junior female
developers and pair them with really
amazing mentors and then also provide
the opportunity for companies to be able
to hire and help change that diversity
problem so I'm always happy to talk
about those things as well am i right on
modern web and I also do a podcast on
modern web so you can check that out and
I love mentoring different whether it's
marketing or development or things like
that so what is a material so no
material just released it's just July
7th I believe was the last release and
it's you know material to beta 8 right
now what they are is it's a material
design components for angular
applications so these are optimized for
angular they're built by the angular
team they integrate seamlessly with your
angular application
pretty awesome I've really enjoyed
playing with it I've been playing with
it since the team told me not to play
with it I was like hey I'm gonna give a
talk on this and they said why please
don't
it was during the alpha phase um and
then I actually tried to use it and I
said okay no I'm not recommending this
but now I do recommend it cuz it's
awesome so we're gonna learn a few
things today we're mostly going to be
playing around in a little bit of code
there's two aspects to angular material
you have components and styling I'll
give you a few tips on getting started a
little your ways that I like to set up
my applications and then we'll just get
into building angular material versions
I'm using today our angular material to
beta eight we're using the latest
version angular 4.34 and angular CLI 1.3
dot Sarah who is an angular developer
that does not use the COI
whoa one okay who who's a- developer
that uses c oh i should see everybody's
hands basically go up that makes me so
happy I came from ember and you know the
only reason I actually started
developing well really developing I
guess was because of the CLI so I
refused to use any technology that
doesn't have a CLI for me um okay so to
two aspects again of ela material we
have components so you have the layout
navigation form controls pop-ups and
modal's
buttons indicators and icons also the
new data table was just released July
7th as well and then we have styling so
with angular material you get access to
the material design colors default
themes those four default themes for you
and then you can also create your own
custom themes here are the 30 available
components in angular material currently
so a lot of really cool buttons I love
the little progress bars they have the
ripple effect pop ups and modal's really
love the little snack bars and tooltips
just basically all the things that pop
up around I mean I really wanted to
create this app where you just like
click on things and then you have these
little snack bars pop up everywhere some
pretty good layout things that you can
basically use the Flex layout as well we
have some navigation love the side nav
I'll be using that in my application
today data table again just came out so
you have the page that the paginate ur
the sort header and the table a lot of
really great form controls things that
people have been really excited about
that have recently come out our date
picker for example who date picker it's
funny how our industry just loves
talking about date pickers gets so
excited about it so material styling
again we have you know the colors of
material design default themes the
custom themes and just recently in the
last release they came out with a
typography configuration so I don't know
if you guys have ever seen a material
palette I love this website so material
palette basically takes the material
design colors and then allows you to
pick and choose so you can sort of see
like which one is the most exciting
color what looks good and then it gives
us a download of the actual palette so
it's pretty amazing check it out on your
free time these are the four pre-built
themes at angular
Sharyl comes with so these are located
in your node modules file that's where
you're gonna be importing it into your
style.css file you have a deep purple
amber indigo pink pink and blue grey and
then purple and green as well you can
create your own custom themes I won't go
over that today but you can check the
guides at material on angular Daioh it's
a just a pretty simple basic step
through guide and again the typography
configuration that was just released you
can check out the guides as well so my
favorite part is building actually
coding with material components so we're
gonna go ahead and get started I'm gonna
spin up an angular CLI app so all you do
there is make sure you have angular CLI
installed and then ng new name of your
application CD into that application and
then make sure to install your
dependencies so to install angular
material just gonna add and go material
recently in the new release they just
came out with the CD k the component dev
kit which is now a dependency that
angular material requires so make sure
to install that animations this is so
for some of the more complex for some of
the more complex transitions animations
will be required and then for some of
the different components hammer J s is
also required so you can go ahead and
add those to your application for the
fonts icons and themes in your global
style CSS file
what I'm doing here is I'm just
importing the Roboto font since I want
to use it outside of my material
components and with throughout my
application and I'm also importing the
material icons which I'll be using and
then I decided that I wanted to for this
demo use the pre-built theme of indigo
pink so I went ahead and imported that
for my note node modules folder so I
also added a little bit of custom CSS
just in case I want to you know add text
color or something like that
I tried desperately to get around that
important I hate using that but
unfortunately like the way the
components are so specific like anyways
just sorry start for the importance
we're gonna go through a component
demonstration today will be these are a
few of them we're gonna go through so
toolbar side nav icon button progress
bar grid list chips dialog race button
cards and a list if you do want to lint
my code while I'm coding feel free to so
let's go ahead and get started
I already spun up a new application so
this is I'm just serving it on localhost
4200 which is the default port for
angular CLI they just created this
really cute little Welcome page for us
so I love it welcome to our app and what
you'll see here is this is actually
using the Roboto font because I already
installed it into my application so let
me go ahead and open up code really
quickly okay so um for those of you who
maybe haven't seen an angular CLI
application before basically what we
have here is we have the main app folder
and then we have the fork fork main app
component file so we have a CSS file
HTML file the spec file and then we have
the TS file I'm another thing you should
take into consideration is the app
module file this is sort of where you're
going to be doing all your imports
declarations over here so that you can
use everything in your application and
what I also did was I'll show you the
Styles file that I have over here so
you'll see here this is where I'm
importing the Roboto font material icons
and then the pre-built themes the
pre-built theme as well and I'm
specifying with a body that I want to
use Roboto
I also added routing to this so I just
created the app routing file and made
all my imports for from angular core and
the router and before I started this I
went ahead and created two components
with the CL I created the about
component and the home component and
this is where I'm specifying the path
for my routes
I went ahead and exported that and then
I'm adding into my app module file right
here I'm importing routing right here
and then I'm adding it to my imports
down here okay so this is what the
general component will look like when
angular CLI generates it for you so we
have our home component
over here and we have our about
component what I haven't created is I
haven't created two other components
that I want so I'm going to go ahead and
do that
ng GC let's see we're gonna create a
team page so let me go ahead and
generate that component first and what
you'll see if you look up over here is
that they created the four files for me
and then they updated the app module
file and I'm also going to create GC I'm
also gonna create an operator as well so
I actually realized I forgot to tell you
what I'm actually building here so um I
am really excited about arcs how many of
you guys use rxjs at all like one a
little bit okay so yeah I mean you sort
of are like our force to be exposed to
it with angular but I'm trying to fix
the rxjs Doc's right now so the closest
I've gone is basically cloned the cloned
the library and created a dummy angular
CLI app but we're getting there so I
figured what I would do is I would just
demo like an rxjs Doc's application here
so anyways I created um two of those
components here so we have an operator's
component we have a team component
another thing I did before this was I
just created two angular services I have
the operator service and just a raise of
data for the different operators and
then a team with an array of data for
the different team and I added some
images into my assets folder as well so
now that we have all that going on and I
just created two new components I want
to go ahead and add that into my app
routing file so let me go ahead and do
that I'm going to go ahead and import
the team component from team component
go ahead and save that and I'm just
going to go ahead and give myself a
little bit of room over here to make
sure nothing's breaking on that side
operators component
from let's see operators operators dark
component go ahead and save that and
then I'll go ahead and define the
different paths I want over here oopsies
it's always weird when your screen is
like exploded into a huge huge thing so
you guys can see it
team component and then I'm gonna go
ahead and add one more over here and
this is going to be the operators
component operators is going to be the
name of the path so if I go ahead and
save that I'm now in order to use the
router of course I need to go ahead and
make sure that I have a router outlet so
I'm just gonna go ahead and add the
router outlet over here save that and
what you should see is you should see
that homeworks over here I specified
home to be the default component that
shows up so okay that works that's
awesome now what I probably want to do
here is I want to make things look a
little bit pretty right so I'm gonna go
ahead and add a little I'm going to use
the side now basically so we're gonna
use the toolbar and we're going to use
the side nav component the other
components we're going to be using our
MD icon and MD button as well so in
order to use material components they
are deprecating this right now there is
material module which I do love but
material module unfortunately has no
tree-shaking so it's not amazing and
they don't want you to do that so we're
going to do is we're gonna go ahead and
import everything we need from angular
material let's see at angular slash
material and let's see so I said I'm
gonna use the MD toolbar module so I'm
using the MD toolbar module I'm using
the MD button module as well because I'm
gonna create a button I'm using the MD
icon module the great thing is you have
to do this once and then it's sort of
there so the empty icon module and then
we're going to use the MD side nav
module as well side nav module go ahead
and save that okay so we have these four
components
we're gonna be using after we've added
it to our imports over here we just need
to add it down here as well all right
just make that pretty okay so now that
I've done that I can go ahead and get
started so let me go ahead and go back
into my app component file and so what
this requires is for the site not to
actually work you're just wrapping
everything in a side nav container so
I'm gonna go ahead and do that the
router outlet needs to go in there as
well go ahead and save that now I want
to have like a nice little bar at the
top called rxjs dock so for that I'm
going to use the MD toolbar and we'll
just say rxjs docks over here go ahead
and save that and you'll see that rxjs
docks is listed the toolbar you can see
but we want to make sure the color it
works so I'm gonna use the pink accent
over here since I'm using this indigo
pink and pink as my accent color so you
can see that's really nice so that works
out and now what I want to do is I want
to create the little side nav right so
in order to do that it's actually called
MD side nav so let me create the side
nav first and I'm gonna give it a local
temperate variable called side nav and
then I'm just gonna use MD toolbar again
in my side nav this is going to be a
stock toolbar so the first row is always
going to be a span and I'm just going to
link it to our default route over here
and then we're going to call this home
over here and then every subsequent one
is actually going to be a MD toolbar row
so let's see and then the router link I
think you guys probably care about since
this is rxjs you guys are going to care
about the operators so we'll make this
the operators route right here and then
we'll call this operators and then we're
just going to do the same thing for
let's see what else do we have we have
the team as well so we'll make that and
we help will have an about page as well
so we'll go ahead and create the about
page too and I like to just make sure
nothing breaks okay so everything is
looking good so far but we obviously
need a button so I want to show you guys
the docs as I'm doing this so you guys
can sort of see where you need to
reference anything if you might ever
have to reference anything if you go to
material angular I oh and you go to the
different components for example right
now we are going to use the side nav so
we can go down and we can go to side now
and you can see the basic side nav so
that's what we're gonna try to do and
you can actually go to view source over
here and then you can see the HTML and
typescript files usually there's nothing
in the CSS for angular material or you
can open it and plunker as well but
anyways so we need to create a button so
for that I'm going to use the material
button I'm going to do that right above
the rxjs docks so this is a button and
it's an MD button go ahead and save that
and within that button I'm going to have
a little I mean use the MD icon and for
the MD icon I'm gonna specify that this
is going to be the hamburger menu so if
I go ahead and save that you should see
the nice little hamburger menu here so
we have a nice little button with a
ripple effect and the pretty little menu
right here so the button obviously
doesn't do anything so I'm going to add
a click event to it and that click event
is going to I called my side nav side
nav south side nav dot toggle and that
is just going to toggle when I click on
that button hopefully and hopefully that
works Oh another thing I want to do by
the way is I'm I'll show you why
actually so so it works but it doesn't
look pretty but it's because the side
nav container is not a full screen so
once I make a full screen yay and you
can see the routes changing over here
and then you can see that it's routing
to the specific components that I want
right about works everything like that
so you know within just a very short
amount of time right we were able to
make a really nice header over here
we're able to make a little side nav
the routes to work use four different
components but now what we want to do is
we probably want something on this
homepage that looks a little bit nicer
so I'm going to go ahead and go to my
home component and I'm just going to
probably create an h1 tag and I'll
probably say welcome to the rxjs Doc's
Doc's test application go ahead and save
that I probably want a little bit of
information actually you know one thing
that I I need over here is I need a
little bit of styling otherwise that's
going to drive me a little bit crazy
so in this router outlet over here I'm
just going to add a div and add the
router outlet in there and then I'm
going to make it class and I think I
called up body margin already go ahead
and save that and I also just want to
center align the text so there we go
okay that looks a little bit better
let's go back to my home component and I
probably want an image so I already
created I think it's in mind let's the
assets start IMG / rxjs thought GMG I
believe there we go we have the little
rxjs logo right there and then we
probably want to say a little bit about
what on earth rxjs is so I'm just going
to take that from the docks that are
already here and rxjs is a library but
for reactive programming using
observables to make it easier to compose
a synchronous or callback based code I
am giving a talk about arcs Jess
tomorrow I believe at ng Sydney so
hopefully I see some of you guys there
otherwise I'm always happy to talk about
it on the Internet okay so we have that
going on let's see what else do we want
here okay so since this is a work in
progress I'm just gonna go ahead and say
it so more work in progress so this is
still a work in progress and you know if
I want to be cute which I do I'm gonna
go ahead and use this let's see we can
use the progress so there's a progress
spinner
which i think is pretty cool and then
you have a progress bar as well so I
think we'll use this progress bar and
again you can just view source over here
and you can see so MD progress bar will
have different modes that you can have
this is in determinants and yeah let's
go ahead and use it so in order to use
it we need to go back into our app
module file and we go ahead and import
it so MD progress bar module go ahead
and save that and then I can go ahead
and add it into my imports down here MD
progress bar module go ahead and save it
if I go back to my home component I can
just use the MD progress bar over here
and you'll see that lets see mode equals
indeterminate the term in it let's go
ahead and save that and see if that
works
okay so I have a nice little progress
bar right here I could do like a value
equals 10 let's say if I wanted to and
it would just default it determinate so
you can see that progress bar is 10 but
I like it the other way because it's
nice and any one not spinning but I
probably also want to make the color be
the accent color the pink since that'll
be nice
okay another button we're gonna use
another button and we'll probably just
add a little button down here and we're
gonna use the the MD raised button so MD
raised button and probably say like
check out the team and we'll add a
router link over here blank equals team
and if I go ahead and save that
that doesn't look that pretty MD race
button color equals well we can make it
primary since I haven't used that
primary color yet okay and maybe add a
little bit of styling here class is
margin
top-20 go ahead and save that okay
that's a little bit better so now we
this routes to the team component which
we don't have anything so let's go ahead
and make a really nice team page so for
this I'm going to use the the grid
component so in order to do that let me
just go ahead and go into my app module
file and import it so I'm also going to
use the list as well down there so MD
grid list module I'm an MD list module
as well I want to import okay and then
make sure to add it over here so MD list
module and then the MD grid list module
go ahead and save that since I'm doing a
team I don't know if you remember but I
did create an angular service called the
team service where I have the person the
commits complements images etc over here
so in order to use this service when you
generate a service with the CLI it's
just ngg service but it doesn't add it
to your app module file so we need to go
ahead and make sure we do that before we
do anything so I'm going to go ahead and
import the team service from team dot
service and then I also have one for the
operator so I'm gonna do that right now
service from operator service okay go
ahead and save that and I need to go
ahead and add that to my providers as
well operator service service and team
service okay go ahead and save that now
what I need to do is I need to go into
that team component I have going to the
typescript file and I need to also
import the service here so team service
from team dot service I believe it is go
ahead and save that and then add it to
my constructor over here so well
call this team data and team service go
ahead and save that okay nothing's
broken so far okay now I can go ahead
and use the data in my application so
let's go back to the team component HTML
file and we don't have anything pretty
here yet so let's just go ahead and say
like the rxjs Dream Team save that and
then what we probably want why does
forgot to delete that over there
okay so rxjs Dream Team let's see okay
we probably want people's faces right so
I'm going to use the grid the material
grid so in order to do that the grids
that all the grid tiles need to go into
a grid list so we'll go ahead and do
that we need to specify the number of
columns otherwise it's not going to work
there's eight people there's a lot more
contributors but I couldn't fit them all
so I decided to just choose eight of the
top contributors and then in each of the
in the grid list goes grid tiles so I'm
going to create little images and let's
see what if I remember where I put this
SS flash image - Ben Lesh thought jpg
speaker images let's see if that works
all right well no it didn't flash assets
flash image / maybe it's yeah that
should probably work it doesn't
is it the in it let's see
I thought it's don't know why it's not
working oh you know why oh my god really
Tracy because I added it everybody's
just last names okay there we go there's
Ben yeah hi Ben okay so um Ben was funny
he's like hey you're giving me talk
about arcs yes
can I add I'll and I'm like yeah sure
it's 2:00 in the morning for you go
ahead uh so anyway so hi Ben okay Ben's
distracting me um what do we need to do
now okay so now that we have the data
we're gonna go ahead and add this grid
towel and we're just going to use ng4
and let image of what did we call it we
called it team data daunt team I believe
okay there's a lot of sense so now that
we have a lot of fans I believe I called
this image so we can just say team I'm
sorry image dot image and it should pop
up everybody except for Matt so funny I
didn't it's like I've run into this like
three times now I'm practicing this talk
and I still haven't edited that but
there we have Matt over there so we have
this really amazing dream team and as
you guys can see it was pretty easy to
start all that using the the grid list
well the grid grid tile grid list but
now what we probably want to do is we
want to have like a list of
accomplishments for these guys so list
of accomplishments and for that I'm just
going to use the MD list component so MD
list
okay so MD list is every basically
everything goes into MD list and then
you have MD list items and I'll just add
tests over here and then we can see that
this works okay and then for each item
and Whitney's ng for again let M team of
team data team go ahead and add that
here
okay and
and let's see team that name person
today call it name or person let's see
person commits and compliment so team
dot person and I should be able to see a
list of the guys okay there we go
I know there's no girls maybe I'll be on
there one day hopefully in a month or
two we'll see how it goes
depending on how well I do with these
socks okay so team person been wash has
team dark commits this is very telling
no I was gonna give him crap about it
but then he's like well it's the quality
REM telling me what's the quality of the
the code and the not the based on the
number of commits so commits on github
he does have the most though and then a
team dot compliment okay so we go ahead
and save that and now we can see about
we used the list to basically say been
wash has 651 commits on github he's so
cool polar bears freeze around him I
meant to say polar bears wear sweaters
around him but it was late I think I did
this out like three in the morning
so um anyways so we have a pretty nice a
team page now right but I think what we
should probably do is focus on this
operators I cannot tell you how painful
it is to look at those dogs
those are XJS talks right now I try to
figure out what the hell those operators
do but anyways problems were solving
slowly um here's the operators service
and I just have an array of operators I
have operator and then details right
here I think what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to use one of my other favorite
components which is the card component
so in order to do that I'm going to go
ahead and import it into my app module
file let's see it's called MD card
module and I'll go ahead and add it over
here as well and then I'm going to also
use the grid like I just did
MD card module go ahead and save that in
order to use the operator service I did
add it into my app module file earlier
but I need to go into my type script
file oops not that one
okay and I need to go ahead and import
it up here as well so operators service
from operator is thought service go
ahead and save that and then add its my
constructor over here we'll call this
operator data operators service okay go
ahead and save that okay I haven't
broken anything yet so I can go back
into my HTML file and I can just start
with the same thing which is a nice h1
tag to say here's a few operators okay
now we have that going and I am going to
go ahead and use the grid again so if
you remember for the MD grid it comes in
a list right so and then we need to
specify the number of columns so for
this one I'm going to have number of
columns b2 and this is consists of tiles
so we'll just add the tiles here in each
tile there this time I'm going to use
the card component so MD card is the
component and then you have the MD card
title title just have a dummy title
right here for now you can see it show
up MD card content over here content
okay so now I have that it doesn't look
very pretty so I'm gonna add a little
bit of styling to this we will call it's
not to the grid let's add this to the
card class equals let's see what do we
want to call it we probably want to call
it card height and width and then just
quickly go into my style CSS file and
just create card height width and
probably a height of like 175 pixels and
width of
300 pixels it's not going to be
amazingly pretty but at least it won't
be like tortuously ugly okay so let's go
to the MD grid tile and I'm gonna use
energy for again love my energy fours
let operator of operator data dot
operators I believe I called okay that
works and then over here it's just
operator dot operator and then operate
our dot what did I call it it's operator
service details so operators component
let's go back operators dot details go
ahead and save that and then you'll see
that there are some nice cards here the
MD card looks really beautiful you can
again specify the content the title a
bunch of other different little things
you can even have card actions and you
have a few different things some of my
favorite operators multi cast I love
that one I like saying it too and then
merge I like merge as well okay so let's
see I want to go back into the angular
material so that I can just show you
guys where you guys can reference it
later on so you have a simple card here
right and you have the card title
subtitle card content you can have a
card image if you want card actions card
footer so a lot of amazing things and
different elements that you can use
within that but no we have we'll see
here's if you operate let me just say
that okay
so now we have everything basically set
up for the about I guess we can create
that really quickly the about component
I think by the way we are looking for
help in rxjs documentation so if you
want to get involved in open source this
is like the perfect way to do it about
this project and then maybe what I want
to do is I just want to add like
an md card and simply use the card to
encapsulate my content like if you're
interested in helping on rxjs docs email
me and you can't email me I'll put my
email address Tracy at this dock oh yay
okay so now we have a really nice
application and you know it really
didn't take me that long to build right
I want to show you guys a few other
little components that we weren't able
to feature in this more serious
application I created this one a few
months ago for ng Vikings and it's a pun
app because I can't do a talk without
having some puns in there so you can see
it uses the tool bar again we have the
nice little side nav over here and then
you know I have a bunch of different
types of puns so here I'm using the card
as well so like why did the cat put oil
on the mouse because it squeaked so you
guys can check this out I deployed it on
firebase it took me about five minutes
to deploy on firebase those are the
cards I'm here over here we didn't go
through the tabs but I love the tab so
this is the tab saying these cattle puns
are so what do you call a cow with a
twitch beef jerky and then I have a
little button here click here if you
thought this was funny haha we thought
it was funny to see cute right so I mean
you can do this and you can close it too
but anyways I mean I don't know who uses
a the snack bars in their production
house any waiting well I need to find
more recently anyways cow pens okay so
then we have banana and this is just
where we use the MD list over here and
then I can go home and I have this
really nice dialog right here so click
here here your instructions click on
emoji and get some magical puns and then
we have a close over here so I can close
it love that it's just so pretty
and over here we have the what are these
called chips chips snack bar delicious
so you can configure these chips over
here but you can see it's really nice to
you just easily add tags and then over
here if you can see if I mouse over the
duck it says oops this isn't done yet
and this is the tooltip so you can
actually specify where you want the
actual tooltip to go and you know I mean
material I think it's it's coming along
pretty well
I know it's still in beta but there's
tons of people using it and I know the
team has a lot more planned so let's go
ahead and get back into the talk we went
through a few of the different
components we saw the tool bar the side
nav the icon the buttons progress bar
grid list chips you saw chips dialog the
raised button empty list I mean a lot of
quiet quite a few different things so I
mean those like 14 14 or so components
if you go to the github you can actually
see the progress so well they'll
actually have a list on github where you
can see all the different ones that are
already done and links to the docs and
the different issues that closes but as
well these are the ones that are in
progress or unplanned I guess so the
tree step or a sticky head virtual
repeat some sorry some of the different
fabs like speed dial and tool bar bottom
nav and bottom sheet as well I'm sure
you guys are excited about flex layout
an angular specs layout Thomas Burleson
who led angular material one he's the
lead on angular material one he created
this really amazing app that demos it I
don't know if it's officially linked I'm
pretty sure it is though but anyways
it's on firebase you can check it out
this is what his site looks like so cool
but you can really play around with flex
layout and just sort of like you know
see what the layout directions mean or
you know whether you line a horizontally
or vertically what the fills looks like
like what flex looks like layout wraps
g/b values etc etc so oh my god who has
heard of angular component dub kit
anybody component def kit one person all
right well I'm so stoked on this so I
spent like two hours being like what is
this a component def kit the other day
it sort of derailed me a little bit but
anyway it's July 6 2017 this is when
angular component def kit was released
and this was released with angular
material to beta 8 so these are the
angular components that you see without
the material design so what they're
doing is they're basically taking like
taking the material design part of it
away so that you can actually create
these components and have building
blocks for you at components so what
that means is you get features so in
this initial release if you do use
component dev kit right now you're going
to get features like the accessibility
at x-direction platform detection
dynamic component instantiation and I
think this is really special this is
really interesting and I think we're
going to see a lot of more companies
sort of moving towards using the dev kit
because obviously like who wants to you
know redo all that and create your own
if you can just like use everybody
else's like the D picker who wants to
create another one so very very very
excited about this I mean there's ton of
downloads already on github I don't
remember how many but it was like in the
tens of thousands daily or something
like that so people are using it and
breaking it mmm
Doc's uh I don't think there are the new
Docs I could be wrong but you can like
bumble through the source code and see
all the exciting things happening there
so I'll probably be writing about this
at some point in time soon so we learned
a few different things today we just
went through components and styling and
angular material little few tips on
getting started I will have a blog
series coming out soon on angular
material I wrote about it I think in
February but so many things have changed
since then and we built an app with
angular material so that was awesome
I'm ladylee it on everything so you know
if you ever need help with anything at
all literally anything I'm more than
happy to help you can follow me on
medium Liddy ladylee comm github etc and
the science that I'm happy to answer any
questions if there are any I think we
have a few minutes otherwise I'm
enjoying Sydney I've been up since
midnight and I haven't slept yet so
we'll see how the we'll see how the rest
of the day goes any questions yes can
you use the material design with react
no because these are actually like
angular components and go specific
components yeah I mean who does react
with material material no so material UI
I asked on Twitter what would the best
one was because I wanted to use it in
one of my react ops people seem to like
material - UI hi Duncan so so I would
use that otherwise there is material I
CSS as well which is a pretty cool
material component library that I used
to use a lot so any other questions I
saw it uh-huh when do I think materials
going to finish beta I don't know
actually I think that with the component
dev kit that just came out and sort of
this decoupling that is really really
really interesting they do plan on
making like I know they say that Igor
Minar who is one of the leads said that
they're going to like de-emphasize
releases but I don't know if that means
that in September they're going to
de-emphasize the release that they have
in September that they've been
emphasizing to me so we'll see um who
knows I know that they're greatly
working on the dev kit right now on a
different team so you know we'll see how
it goes I think it'll be a second I mean
it's gotta be like
six months to a year but that's just my
random predictions I'm predicting more
like a year but any other questions yes
sorry the question was
other component libraries okay so can
you use Z so there's a component dev kit
and then there's the dev kit so yeah so
like the component dev kit you can use
with other you know what I'm not really
sure I mean they are angular specific
components though uh-huh yeah I mean I'm
pretty sure with a component of kit you
can specify whatever styles you want so
if you use it I don't know I'm actually
really curious about that you were gonna
say oh yeah yeah I was actually thinking
that I was actually thinking about if
I'm gonna demo this do I do I you know
use these UI components with the
component defecate with um with
bootstrap but I feel like that would
sort of be like going back in time
versus cool well thank you everybody for
coming
I'll see you guys around the conference
and again I'm happy to help or answer
any questions any time you need
[Applause]